I'm on the train going up the coke about
the mountain in Rio de Janeiro in Brazil
going to see one of the most famous
monuments in the whole of Brazil the
statue of Christ the Redeemer and we're
going to talk about some interesting
chemistry when we get there there is a
story that Albert Einstein traveled on
this train
so this is really a homage to him as
well so here we are on the summit of the
Corcovado and behind me is the famous
statue of Christ the Redeemer it's
nearly a hundred and thirty feet high
just under 40 meters high and 30 meters
wide and there are a huge number of
people here the statue is made from
soapstone it's a very soft stone and
inside it has concrete reinforced with
iron rods steel rods to give it strength
but soapstone is one of the softest
stones you can have and it is very
similar in chemical composition to baby
powder talc this sort of powder that you
put on babies
chemically talc is derived from
magnesium silicate magnesium and SiO 4
to minus ions and because it's ionic and
has discrete ions in the structure it's
quite soft it's easy to break up but
soapstone is related to talc but has
been underground at high pressure and
high temperature and it is transformed
into a stronger rock but it's still
really quite soft and you can cut it
quite easily so you can sculpt the head
of Christ this statue doesn't fall apart
because although the soapstone is for
soft it's just on the surface the whole
surface is covered with triangles of
soapstone rather like a mosaic and these
have been cut to give the features of
Christ and soapstone is a very nice and
smooth rock it feels rather like the
talc when you put it on your skin it
makes your skin all soft and smooth
that's why they put it on babies now we
can't go near the statue because it's
far too high where the soapstone starts
but Brady's thought of that and he's
brought about backup so I have in here a
small statue made of soapstone you can
see it looks just the same as the real
thing but when I stroke the stone it
feels just like soap and you can see it
had been carved really quite intricately
and easily because the soapstone is so
soft the erosion of stone is often
caused by very bad weather snow and ice
because when water freezes it breaks up
the stone and here we are in Rio one of
the warmer cities in the world
though it doesn't feel like that today
and so there's very rarely any frost and
that is why it isn't damaged but it has
been damaged by lightning and because
it's right at the top of a mountain and
about four or five years ago it was
struck by lightning and required quite
extensive restoration to repair the
damage so now it has got several
lightning conductors probably made of
copper to conduct the electricity down
without damaging the stone
we've now got to the base of the statue
and in the guidebooks they don't really
say anything about the base and the base
is made it's covered with marble marble
is calcium carbonate and you can polish
it to a high brightness it's almost like
a mirror you might be able to see my
face inside it reflected in it and I
think they chose this because it looks
nice but I think there's another reason
and the reason is that marble is much
harder than soapstone and I think they
chose it to stop people scratching their
names onto the stone because even with
the Barrow you could scratch soapstone
and so in the eighty years it's been
here there would be hundreds of names
over it but the marble you can see is
still as good as new
[Music]
I think it's not really very impressive
it really looms over you dominates this
crowd of people and from the center of
the town
it looks really mysterious especially on
a day like today when there lots of
clouds and Christ appears through the
clouds and there disappears again
it's really very effective and the
science is also interesting but there is
also one fact which is quite surprising
is that this mountain is made out of a
different rock it's made out of granite
which is one of the hardest minerals so
there is something very symbolic about
the statue of Christ which is very soft
standing on the hard earth and I'm sure
many people can read all sorts of
significance into that I don't feel any
significance except as a fantastic
demonstration of the definite different
powers of materials how different
chemical composition can give you such
different properties